functional foods, fortified foods. They sound good for you, but they may actually be sabotaging your healthy diet. In this episode, we talk with one psychologist who studies how companies market foods to health conscious consumers and why we should all be wary of what they tell us about their products. Laura Spatari-Korneish is a marketing and advertising professor at Coventry University in the United Kingdom. She studies how foods are marketed to consumers and how that affects our decisions about what to eat. Welcome, Dr. Spatery Cornish. Thank you. I'm very happy to be here. First of all, what is a functional food? Okay, so a functional food basically is any food that has been fortified in some way. Now, what that means is they have added vitamins or minerals to a food
功能性食品、强化食品。听起来对健康有益，但它们实际上可能会破坏你的健康饮食。在本期节目中，我们采访了一位心理学家，她专门研究公司如何向注重健康的消费者营销食品，以及为什么我们都应该对他们宣传的产品保持警惕。劳拉·斯帕塔里-科尔尼什（Laura Spatari-Korneish）是英国考文垂大学的市场营销与广告学教授。她研究食品是如何向消费者营销的，以及这如何影响我们对吃什么的决定。欢迎你，斯帕塔里-科尔尼什博士。谢谢。我很高兴来到这里。首先，什么是功能性食品？好的，功能性食品基本上是指以某种方式进行了营养强化的食品。这意味着他们在食品中添加了维生素或矿物质
over and above of what it actually is. It's very, very common. So if you have corn flakes and it's basically fortified with vitamin A, that is actually a functional food. Or if you have blue, bread and in the bread they say it's fortified with omega-3, that is also a functional food. So we find them everywhere on the shelves in our supermarkets. Would you say that functional foods are actually more of a marketing tool? Do they influence what people decide to eat based on the fortification of these foods? Yes. I want to just take you a step back and say that actually most foods are marketing tools. So ever since industrialization has happened and foods have been processed. Marketers have done a lot of research into our taste, into our desires of food.
超出了其本身含有的成分。这非常非常普遍。如果你吃玉米片，里面基本上强化了维生素A，那实际上就是功能性食品。或者如果你吃某种蓝莓面包，面包上说强化了欧米伽-3，这也是一种功能性食品。所以我们在超市货架上到处都能找到它们。你会说功能性食品实际上更多是一种营销工具吗？它们会根据这些食品的营养强化来影响人们的饮食决策吗？是的。我想先带大家倒退一步，实际上大多数食品都是营销工具。自从工业化发生、食品经过加工以来，营销人员对我们的口味、对我们对食物的渴望进行了大量的研究。
So, you know, they use a lot of processes to give us the foods we actually love. That's why sometimes we can't stop eating. And on top of that, they make them more and more convenient. Now, functional foods basically have arrived as a result of the fact that they noticed that consumers have paid more and more attention to health. And this understanding that health is related to food. So marketers have immediately jumped on this. and decided to say, we are going to offer foods that are actually also going to offer some health benefits. So functional foods in that case are a very, very powerful marketing tool
所以，你知道，他们使用了很多加工过程来给我们提供我们真正喜爱的食物。这就是为什么有时候我们停不下来地吃。最重要的是，他们让食物变得越来越便利。现在，功能性食品的出现，基本上是因为他们注意到消费者对健康的关注度越来越高，并且人们开始理解健康与食物息息相关。因此，营销人员立即抓住了这一点，并决定推出不仅能填饱肚子、还能提供一些健康益处的食品。所以在这种情况下，功能性食品是一个非常非常强大的营销工具
because marketers use them to offer people, look, you are afraid, you might get sick of you eat the wrong food. So buy these foods, and these foods will actually give you all the nutrients you need, and they will actually make you healthy. And people do believe in that. So yes, they are very, very powerful marketing tool. What does your research tell us about the nutritional, actual nutritional value of functional foods? Can they be good for you?
因为营销人员用它们来向人们传达：看吧，如果你吃了不对的食物，你可能会害怕生病。所以买这些食品吧，这些食品实际上会为你提供所需的所有营养，并且能让你保持健康。人们确实相信这一点。所以是的，它们是一个非常非常强大的营销工具。你的研究告诉我们关于功能性食品的营养价值、实际营养价值是什么？它们对你有好处吗？
Well, there are two types of functional foods, and I've done some research about this, and I've asked a lot of people about how they consume functional foods. But essentially, even when talking to nutritionists, what they say is that there are nutritionally rich functional foods. These are the foods that have actually been scientifically proven to be good for you. And there's not that many, you'd be surprised. but for example, cholesterol lowering spread has actually been proven it does really lower cholesterol, and some of the probiotic yogurts or probiotic drinks have been proven to help. But unfortunately, there are the nutritionally poor functional foods.
嗯，功能性食品有两种类型，我对此做过一些研究，也问过很多人关于他们如何消费功能性食品的看法。但本质上，即使与营养学家交谈，他们的说法是，存在营养丰富的功能性食品。这些是经过科学证明对你有好处的食品。而且数量其实没那么多，你会感到惊讶。但例如，降胆固醇涂抹酱确实被证明可以真正降低胆固醇，一些益生菌酸奶或益生菌饮料也被证明有帮助。但不幸的是，还有营养贫乏的功能性食品。
Now, these foods usually are even a bit like junk foods, I say, but then they add minerals and vitamins to them. So you can have, for example, a cereal bar that has 80% of your fibre needs, which makes it a functional food. but the reality is very high in calories, high in fat, high in sugar, high in salt. The same thing with many cereals. So a common cereal, at least in the UK, is cocoa pops, for example, for children. And parents buy it because it's very chocolatey.
现在，这些食品通常甚至有点像垃圾食品，我说，但随后它们在其中添加了矿物质和维生素。所以你可以买到，例如，含有你85%纤维需求的谷物棒，这使它成为一种功能性食品。但现实是它的卡路里很高、脂肪很高、糖很高、盐很高。许多麦片也是如此。因此，至少在英国，一种常见的麦片是针对儿童的巧可力爆米花（Cocoa Pops），例如。家长买它是因为它很有巧克力味。
But it also has added fibre, added folic acid and other vitamins and minerals. But if you look at the amount of sugar that there is in the cereal, it makes it very, very unhealthy. There are some good, but I think there's 80% of functional foods. They're not really as healthy as people think. So when can these foods be good for you? So it's important to look at the labels because even the nutritionally poor functional foods, you know, sometimes they're okay because they do have nutrients, they have vitamins, they have minerals, they have fiber. But what is really important is you can't use these foods instead of something a lot healthier. So what I found in my research is I have a lot of people who really don't like fruits and really don't like vegetables, but they're aware that they're missing out on fiber and minerals.
但它也添加了纤维、叶酸以及其他维生素和矿物质。如果你看一下麦片中的含糖量，就会发现它非常非常不健康。虽然有一些好的，但我认为80%的功能性食品并没有人们想象的那么健康。那么这些食品什么时候对你有好处呢？所以查看标签很重要，因为即使是营养贫乏的功能性食品，你知道，有时它们也还可以，因为它们确实含有营养成分、维生素、矿物质、纤维。但真正重要的是，你不能用这些食品来代替更健康的东西。所以我从研究中发现，有很多人真的很不喜欢水果，也真的很不喜欢蔬菜，但他们意识到自己缺乏纤维、矿物质
and vitamins. So many of them, strangely enough, instead of buying the fruits and vegetables, they buy functional foods because they think they'll get the fiber from there or the vitamins from there. But the realities people need to understand that the source of nutrients is as important as the nutrient itself. The fiber you get from a chocolate cereal bar is not the same as the fiber you get from broccoli or any other fruit and vegetable. So yes, it's okay if overall, you know, you have a nice, good diet full of fruits and vegetables and lean meats and you had a cereal bar or a fortified cereal, but you can't use it to substitute, you know, really good, healthy foods like fruits and vegetables and whole grains.
和维生素。所以他们中的许多人，奇怪的是，没有去买水果和蔬菜，而是去买功能性食品，因为他们认为可以从中获取纤维或维生素。但现实是人们需要明白，营养素的来源和营养素本身一样重要。你从巧克力谷物棒中获得的纤维与你从西兰花或任何其他水果和蔬菜中获得的纤维是不一样的。所以是的，如果总的来说，你知道，你有一个富含水果、蔬菜和瘦肉的良好饮食习惯，并且你吃了一根谷物棒或强化麦片，这没问题，但你不能用它来替代真正优质的健康食品，比如水果、蔬菜和全谷物。
So no easy way. There's really no, absolutely no easy way. And the reality is they're so popular because supermarkets have told us that the easy way is the right way. And, you know, we're lazy as human beings. And that's okay. I mean, we work really hard. We have long hours. So we want a diet which is easier, but it's also good and it's also healthy. We want everything. And the reality is you have to make sacrifices and, you know, you have to make sure that you make the right decisions and that usually requires work and effort. There seems to be a lack of consensus among marketers and how to advertise healthy foods to consumers. What is the most important information about the food you buy when you're trying to maintain a healthy diet? It is a very, very big business
所以没有捷径。真的没有，绝对没有捷径。现实之所以它们如此受欢迎，是因为超市告诉我们捷径就是正确的路。而且，你知道，作为人类我们很懒惰。这没关系。我的意思是，我们工作真的很努力。我们工作时间很长。所以我们想要一种更轻松但同时又好又健康的饮食。我们什么都想要。现实是你必须做出牺牲，并且，你知道，你必须确保你做出正确的决定，这通常需要工作和努力。营销人员在如何向消费者宣传健康食品方面似乎缺乏共识。当你试图保持健康饮食时，关于你购买的食物，最重要的是什么信息？这是一个非常非常大的生意
and if you read work about how supermarkets work you can see that they put a lot of thought into trying to make us believe that this is really, really healthy and that's where you need to go because obviously supermarkets are a business and they're there to make money
如果你阅读关于超市如何运作的著作，你会发现他们花了很多心思让我们相信这真的非常非常健康，这就是你需要去的地方，因为显而易见，超市是一项生意，它们的存在是为了赚钱
not to make us healthier. So it's up to us as consumers to be smart about our decisions, choose real foods, actual foods, not processed foods, look at the labels. You need to choose foods that have very few ingredients.
而不是为了让我们更健康。所以作为消费者，我们需要聪明地做出决定，选择真实的食物、实际的食物，而不是加工食品，查看标签。你需要选择成分非常少的食物。
When ingredients starts to get into 10, 20 ingredients, there's a problem. And the reality is the majority of those ingredients will be additives and chemicals. So this is a question a lot of people might want to ask you. If I want to lose weight, what will be the most likely outcome of reaching for convenience foods?
当配料开始达到10种、20种时，就有问题了。现实是，这些成分的大多数都是添加剂和化学物质。所以这是很多人可能会问你的一个问题。如果我想减肥，选择便利食品最可能的结局是什么？
It doesn't matter if you're fat or thin, really. It's just a question that with convenience foods, one, you're not going to lose weight because of all the chemicals and additives. There has been recent research that shows that if you drink diet soda, you're still more likely to put on weight than if you, you know, drink water. And the reason is that the chemicals like aspartame or other sweeteners in the diet soda, they make your stomach want food. So it kind of your stomach is saying, okay, I can sense that this is something sweet. Where is the food? So then it makes you eat a lot more afterwards.
不管你是胖还是瘦，真的。这只是一个问题，对于便利食品，第一，你不会减肥，因为里面有各种化学物质和添加剂。最近的研究表明，如果你喝健怡苏打水，你依然比喝水更容易发胖。原因在于健怡苏打水中的阿斯巴甜或其他甜味剂等化学物质会让你的胃想要食物。所以这有点像你的胃在说，好吧，我能感觉到这是甜的东西。食物在哪里？然后它会让你在之后吃得更多。
So even if you try to eat diet foods, first of all, you are still going to. to put on weight. Secondly, keep in mind that with diet foods, the reality is for them to remove the fat, they have to add something else, and usually that's going to be sugar. So most convenient foods, you can't cheat, even if you go for the diet versions. They're low in nutrients, they're full of chemicals, they're not good for you, they leave you undernourished, and they leave you fat. I've also heard that people who eat what they think are healthy foods, like what you're talking about, functional foods, are also, well, I ate healthy today. I had that healthy cereal bar. can splurge at dinner, right? They compensate or they think they've already made the sacrifice.
所以即使你试图吃减肥食品，首先，你仍然会发胖。其次，请记住，对于减肥食品，现实是，为了去除脂肪，他们必须添加其他东西，通常那会是糖。所以大多数便利食品，你无法作弊，即使你选择减肥版本。它们营养成分低，充满化学物质，对你没有好处，让你营养不良，让你发胖。我还听说，吃他们认为是健康食品的人，就像你说的功能性食品，也是……嗯，我今天吃得很健康。我吃了那根健康的谷物棒。所以可以在晚餐时大吃一顿，对吧？他们会补偿，或者他们认为自己已经做出了牺牲。
Is that something you found in your research? I found a lot in two different ways. One, how you said, and two, as in you go and you splurge and you have an Indian or a Chinese and then you get drunk. And then the next day you have a functional food to compensate. The reality is the body doesn't work like that. It works day by day. So if in this particular day you have really eating poorly, you can't just compensate by eating functional foods. You can try to compensate by eating fruits and vegetables, but even that doesn't really compensate, let alone if you just have a functional food. Because these foods, yes, they can be a nice addition to your diet, but they shouldn't compensate for bad eating ever. How important is psychology in helping
这是你在研究中发现的吗？我从两个不同的方面发现了这一点。第一，就像你说的，第二，比如你出去大吃一顿，吃一顿印度菜或中国菜，然后喝醉了。第二天你吃功能性食品来补偿。现实是身体不是那样运作的。它是日复一日运作的。所以如果在这特定的一天你真的吃得很差，你不能仅仅通过吃功能性食品来补偿。你可以尝试通过吃水果和蔬菜来补偿，但即使那样也无法真正补偿，更不用说如果你只是吃功能性食品了。因为这些食品，是的，它们可以是你饮食中很好的补充，但它们绝不应该用来补偿不良饮食。心理学在帮助
people understand how they eat and what they eat? Right, so psychology is actually vital, and the reason is because it deals as a science with all the processes that we as consumers go through in terms of the food we consume. So let me give you just an example. If you're eating chocolate because you're bored or because you're lonely or you had a hard day at work, psychology will tell you that this has to do with your mood and trying to make sure that you regulate your mood. So it studies why you behave in a certain way. It also tells us that if you, for example, eat badly, not because you want to eat badly, but because you feel, I don't have the willpower to eat well. Psychology tells us that it has to do with your self-afficacy, with
人们理解他们如何吃以及吃什么方面有多重要？好的，所以心理学实际上至关重要，原因在于它作为一门科学，处理了我们作为消费者在所消费的食物方面经历的所有过程。让我举个例子。如果你因为无聊、孤独或工作辛苦了一天而吃巧克力，心理学会告诉你，这与你的情绪有关，并试图确保你调节自己的情绪。所以它研究你为什么会有某种行为。它还告诉我们，如果你，例如，饮食习惯不好，不是因为你想吃得不好，而是因为你觉得自己没有坚持健康饮食的意志力。心理学告诉我们，这与你的自我效能感有关，与
your belief in yourself and your ability to change your eating habits. So, Basically with psychology, it tracks us from the beginning, how we choose the foods that we choose, what we choose, why we choose them, how we eat it, and the role that food plays in our life. So for some people, food is just fuel. For other people, food means love. And again, psychology, there's a lot of research that tries to understand, okay, why is it that food actually is equated with love? And how does it deal with the way we were brought up and our families and our culture? So in terms of psychology, basically, it deals with every single step from how we think about food and what types of food we think about till the process in which we're actually sitting down and consuming the food. So as a science, it's the best possible way that we have to explain the position that food holds in our lives.
你对自己的信念以及改变饮食习惯的能力有关。所以，基本上有了心理学，它从一开始就追踪我们，我们如何选择我们选择的食物、我们选择什么、我们为什么选择它们、我们如何吃它，以及食物在我们生活中扮演的角色。对某些人来说，食物只是燃料。对其他人来说，食物意味着爱。同样，心理学有大量的研究试图去理解，为什么食物实际上等同于爱？它如何与我们的成长方式、我们的家庭和我们的文化相关联？所以在心理学方面，基本上，它处理从我们如何思考食物以及我们思考哪种类型的食物，到我们实际坐下来消费食物的过程的每一步。所以作为一门科学，它是我们解释食物在我们生活中所占地位的最好方式。
Great. Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Spateri Cornish. Very welcome. And thank you for listening. Please visit our website. org to listen to more episodes. I'm Audrey Hamilton with the American Psychological Associations, speaking of psychology. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
太棒了。非常感谢您加入我们，斯帕塔里-科尔尼什博士。不客气。谢谢您的收听。请访问我们的网站 .org 收听更多剧集。我是来自美国心理学协会的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿（Audrey Hamilton），这里是“心理学话你知”（Speaking of Psychology）。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可留下评论。